[Music]
hey guys hope you're good
Samuel leads here and right now I'm in a
Ugandan hospital so basically I had a
quite a serious accident I fell down a
waterfall single-handedly and shard my
kneecap and broke it in a few different
parts so I was a little bit scared I'm
not gonna lie I'm scared because I'm
thinking I'm now in a Ugandan hospital
on my own and I don't know anybody
around the area my team are gonna be
12-hour 12 hours away from from me on my
own I don't know if the hospital are
going to be good bad I got I know that I
have some serious operations surgery and
stuff I know what's gonna happen but you
know what it's been absolutely blissful
couple of days so far I have got been in
this Ugandan hospital I think for ten
days and then we'll go in crutches for
some time as well got a cast on my leg
the moment but you know I really believe
everything happens for a reason I so
believe that there's been so much glory
and so many good things that have
happened from this I mean for a start I
didn't cuz I wasn't there anyone that
fell down that waterfall whole bunch of
us fell and I'm glad no one died but I
think it happened for a reason I think
that I wasn't meant to go with the team
to the works that we do the reason I
think I wasn't meant to go is because I
think they they thought oh god I think
my team would have observed me but now
because I'm not their team they don't
have to pull the boots up and get to
work and step up and do it I think
that's incredible so Russell my brother
he's team leader now and then the other
guys they're really gonna have to sabor
him now it's it's you know sorry I did a
workshop that they've all called warrior
warrior workshop had to be a soldier had
to be a warrior which is about acting in
spite of your mood
and in spite of circumstances and then
what a brilliant way to put into
practice actually have a real serious
action then you find out if you're a
real warrior you can say you're a
warrior but until you have an accident
or a serious problem you know you can
talk in the classroom all day long so
anyway I had the accident which the
hospital told the team to go on
they left is like maybe nine of them
they all left
very well looked after in this hospital
and surgery was very smooth my team I do
so went out there but wait to hear the
stories the bit another thing as well
they did charity work and also business
workshops but while I'm in hospital I've
been meeting people and having
opportunities because one of the things
that I thought was that if I didn't have
the money to pay for this operation I
would have been in such a bad way
there's people a kasbahs up that do not
have money to pay for the hospital and
they need it so being in the hospital
myself I can now see them appreciate
that more we came to Uganda to do
business to run business workshops and
to help people and to run the child's
and stuff that we're doing but I think
one of the things I feel passionate
right now about and I said this is the
doctor I did say this yeah I said to the
doc she's beautiful by the way
it's my nurse beautiful Muslim lady
amazing lady and I said to the doctor I
said if there's anyone while I'm in this
hospital for these ten days anyone that
comes to the hospital and there and they
need surgery or whatever if they haven't
got the money
don't turn them away come and tell me
tell me I'm not trying to be here Oh our
maids and everything like that
it was saying I'm glad I'm here because
it helps open an opportunity to help
people
you know warriors do hard things
warriors do things despite that mood I
don't care how I'm feeling right now I
don't care how I'm feeling right now I'm
gonna do whatever it takes to get the
mission done and my team right now
killing it in kabali uganda they've run
in there digging balls building water
tanks helping orphans widows people that
have got nothing but regardless of what
happens it's not about what happens to
you is about how you spawn do I really
believe that it's never about what
happens to use behaviour lookit I one
more thing very important thing I mean I
was planning on doing this challenge in
August well I give up everything I've
got all my money everything I've become
financially free all over again and
filming and documents it starting from
nothing and when this happened with the
bonamo now I'm gonna be I've got cast on
and you know my crutches all that jazz
I'm thinking our car won't go to that
challenge like was planning on doing it
next month in August but then I thought
actually I'm really pleased because now
if I can do it with if I can still
become financially free all over again
with no money in a new location and
everything in a freaking wheelchair or
on crutches then there's no excuses then
so I'm really glad actually I'm glad
this has happened it'll be a pain
because then a got metal in my leg next
with my leg every time I go in an
airplane after I know Oh bleep but I'm
pleased because next month if I can
become financially free all over again
and stop buying houses and doing deals
or making money starting with nothing in
a new area in a freaking wheelchair or
on crutches then that shows there's no
excuses anyone can do this with the
right knowledge piece god bless you
subscribe share the video if it's Tara
if you terribly and don't share it or
you can share it I don't mind
I love you guys